there was that weird stretch
after joe budden left everyday struggle
when they had star on there
and that [ __ ] was wack cause it was
almost like they're kind of both the
same dude
there was like no voice of reason in the
room
bro a lot of you know the thing with
star a lot of people get star flag bro i
when i was in high school i used to wake
up early in the morning hairstyle
no i mean he's a radio legend yeah but i
think the thing is is that like
because even me i didn't know nothing
about what i'm doing now
right now i started but like star i love
star for who he is i love that him talk
crazy but it's not the same platform
it's not the same platform and i think
when you have him and academics
it's almost like there's no like voice
of reason in the room that's really
con but yo academics he does have voice
of reason but everybody wants to combat
it i think the thing is is like
you know we accept the message depending
on the messenger
and like some of the messages that he
may have
if you be around him and you sit with
him and you know him they make sense
right but if you don't know him you're
like who the [ __ ] is he to say something
why should he have the right to it
should be me or it should be somebody
else so it should be
and he he says a lot of [ __ ] that man he
say a lot of [ __ ] that don't make sense
to me
right that's my brother though like i
[ __ ] with no matter what yeah i think
for me like the academics thing i think
that
i've always had a lot of respect for
somebody who literally built up a
platform from their bedroom
right right you know what i mean and
you're right like he's had
some wild [ __ ] that he'll say like but
you know what i learned
from about the wild [ __ ] that he says
you gotta remember bro i was like
i always look at life is like life is a
movie and everybody's playing roles
right
in different roles a lot of people don't
know the roles that they're playing
he's fully aware of the role he's
playing and he knows how to enter he
leans into it he leans into it he
knows how to entertain within that role
see when i got bro when i got on
everyday struggle
i never entertained nobody in my life
mm-hmm like i come from the hood like i
don't say that it's a mindset it's not
a different place i come from a hood
right i come from like a certain type of
background
so i don't understand i understand being
entertained but i understand how to
entertain
and that's what i learned from academics
you know what i mean like a lot of the
silly [ __ ] he does
he'll he'll wrap that around a message
but you you looking at all the other
[ __ ] and you
by the time you get to it you're like uh
he kind of got a point but [ __ ] him
cause we don't like him that's all it
really is bro people just don't like him
but they don't know